it's been about nine months since apple
revealed their incredible m1 chip at
last year's november event so what i
wanted to do for this video is review
the history of the m1 including the
original roots of this chip and then i
wanted to see how it currently stands in
terms of value efficiency and
performance compared to when it first
came out and then finally i want to take
a little sneak peek into the future
apple silicon mac chips like the m1x and
the m2 starting off with the history of
the m1 ship i want to go back
way back i did a little digging and i
found this very interesting article
concerning a former senior apple
engineer who claimed that way back in
the day apple began planning its own
alternative to intel processors apple
started work on what would become the m1
10 years ago in 2010 when they contacted
arm to develop a custom 64-bit
instruction set architecture and if you
didn't already know basically every
single smartphone and computer chip
today uses a 64-bit isa
which is why the m1 absolutely had to be
a 64-bit chip in order to run the most
common modern apps which are built to
support 64-bit because 32-bit only
supports a maximum of 4 gigabytes of ram
which is obviously too little for many
apps so apparently apple approached arm
even before they finished designing
their own basic 32-bit chip and fun fact
in 2011 the 32-bit arm architecture was
the most widely used architecture in
mobile devices and then in 2013 this
happened the 5s
is the most forward-thinking phone we've
ever created in fact perhaps the most
forward-thinking phone anyone has ever
made a7 is 64-bit
this is the first ever
in a phone
of any kind
i don't think the other guys are even
talking about it yet now phil schiller's
words were true because a full year
later samsung revealed the galaxy note 4
which came packing the snapdragon 805
chip which was still using a 32-bit
architecture and less than a week after
that apple revealed the iphone 6 with
their a8 chip which was their second
generation 64-bit chip basically giving
apple a huge head start in terms of
64-bit chip design and to this day
apple's a-series chips are way ahead of
anything qualcomm or samsung can design
in single core multi-core and graphics
performance and if you think about it
it's all thanks to apple's idea of
making their own chips for the mac way
back in 2010 and according to chakran
apple had specific plans for how their
chip would work so they asked arm to
create the 64-bit isa which became rm64
so what he's basically trying to say is
that the arm 64 instruction set
architecture that we know today is only
here because of apple approaching arm
over 10 years ago to create this
specific 64-bit architecture and if
you're having a hard time believing that
apple was planning for their future m1
ship way back in 2010 let me take you
through a list of changes that apple
absolutely had to make in order to make
the m1 max possible today in 2014 apple
introduced their very own metal graphics
api for ios to replace the open standard
opengl api which apple believed had way
too much overhead and then a year later
apple brought metal to the mac which
improved rendering performance by up to
50 percent and it improved efficiency by
up to 40
which are two extremely important
aspects of the current m1 max especially
efficiency and then in 2017 apple
introduced metal 2 which further
improved performance as well as machine
learning performance and they even
announced metal 4 vr basically showing
that apple wants to use metal for every
single apple device going forward
including their rumored vr and ar
headsets and then moving forward in 2018
apple made the bombshell announcement
that mac os mojave is deprecating opengl
across all platforms and pushing
developers towards using metal for
better performance and efficiency now
this really upset game developers
because they didn't want to have to
rewrite their games to support metal and
with that came the announcement that
mojave requires a graphics card that
supports metal and this ultimately meant
that nvidia gpu support was gone and
then in 2019 apple officially dropped
support for 32-bit apps with mac os
catalina which basically broke all
32-bit games and made a lot of people
upset but now we finally know that apple
was making all of those frustrating
moves because they were literally
planning for their apple silicon m1 chip
the entire time so let me explain why
the m1 chip has no support for 32-bit
apps in the hardware at all which allows
it to focus on 64-bit apps so they can
run faster without all of the extra
overhead needed to support 32-bit apps
and because the m1 only supports 64-bit
apple was able to create rosetta which
automatically translates x86 64-bit code
to arm 64 making basically every old mac
program run perfectly fine without
needing to be updated with full apple
silicon support which is the number one
reason why the m1 max became so
successful and because apple was
planning to use the same apple silicon
architecture across all of their devices
including the mac the iphone ipad
everything apple needed their own
graphics api that was as efficient as
possible to improve performance and
battery life and that was of course
metal and only because of metal ipad and
iphone apps automatically run on m1 max
which is a huge feature for apple metal
is also what allows the m1 chip to have
such impressive graphics performance
while barely sipping any power just 5.6
watts at full load compared to 45 watts
on the 16 inch macbook pros 5300m gpu
which is actually only slightly faster
than the m1 gpu so the point that i'm
trying to make is that apple has been
planning the m1 chip for an entire
decade with many steps made over the
past few years to get developers to
slowly support apple silicon on the mac
without them even knowing about it but
with that said before i explained how
the m1 chip is so powerful i want to
take a look at how the m1 chip stands
against the competing chips that are
just coming out today and some that
haven't even been released yet when the
m1 chip first came out we compared it to
the best consumer laptop ship out there
the amd 4900 hs and to our surprise the
m1 smoked it in terms of single core
performance being 42 percent faster and
it was just slightly behind in terms of
multi-core performance in geekbench 5.
however in cinebench r23 the amd chip
was 30 faster than the m1 but what's
also important to note is that it was
using 53 watts of power to get that
score compared to only 15 watts on the
m1 and surprisingly the m1 was somehow
faster in some tests like lightroom
classic raw photo exporting and almost
as fast for things like 4k video
exporting and final cut pro because of
optimization and that same optimization
allowed the m1 macbook air for 999
outperform a 3899
16-inch macbook pro and tests like xcode
programming and certain video editing
tests like hevc stabilization and r5 10
bit 422 exporting because of its modern
hardware encoders and for other common
tests like 4k editing it performed
impressively close considering the
massive price difference and then
recently we compared the m1 macbook air
to laptops that are actually in its
weight class like the lg gram 14 which
is actually 200 more expensive and the
m1 absolutely destroyed it in every
single way from the build quality and
performance all the way to battery life
we then compared it to both the intel
and amd models on the new surface laptop
4 from a couple of months ago and the m1
air was faster in basically every test
especially when you unplug the surface
laptops from power making them slow down
even more and for real-world editing
work the m1 absolutely killed them
especially for 4k video editing we tried
it again with the new galaxy book pro
and once again we saw the same results
with the m1 outperforming it in every
single test but now moving on to future
chips we just got some leaks of intel's
alder lake chips that are going to be
competing with apple's m1 chip in
premium thin and light laptops when they
release in the first quarter of next
year and in the leaked benchmark for the
14 core chip model it scored only around
1250 points in single core and 6800
points in multi-core so it's still going
to be slower than apple's m1 chip
especially in terms of single core
performance and then comparing amd's
latest zen 3
5800u mobile laptop chip which is meant
to compete with the m1 the amd chip is
consistently slower than the m1 in both
single and multi-core performance so we
can basically see that even nine months
later the m1 chip is still holding its
own against competing chips in its
market segment and as we all know the
next version of the m1 which is the m1x
is coming out within the next couple of
months and we're expecting it to have
insanely powerful performance being the
fastest laptop ship in the world with an
estimated multi-core score of around 14
350 points but getting back to the m1
chip and why it's so fast let me lay out
the basics before getting into some very
interesting tidbits that give it a huge
advantage first off the chip itself is
built on the most advanced chip node in
the world right now tsmc's 5 nanometer
process allowing it to pack in 16
billion transistors on top of that
everything from the cpu the gpu the 16
core neural engine the thunderbolt
controller the machine learning
accelerators the dedicated video
encoding chips and the memory is packed
into a single chip package which greatly
reduces the distance that data needs to
travel between each component which
reduces latency and improves performance
the m1 also uses a unified memory
architecture which means that all of
those components mainly the cpu and the
gpu can access data from the ram at the
same time without having to copy it back
and forth to work on it like traditional
x86 chips do going further each core
within the 8 core gpu has its own
dedicated tile memory and extra cash so
that it doesn't have to access the ram
as often which optimizes performance but
now getting into some of the more
advanced details that most people don't
know about this brings us to an article
from eric enchine according to him the
m1 chip has a total of eight decoders
which is unheard of since most of the
best chips from amd and intel are
limited to four of them decoders
basically take machine code instructions
and chop them up into micro ops which
gets sent to the instruction buffer
where they wait for the chip to process
them so having eight of them instead of
four greatly improves performance and on
top of that the instruction buffer on
the m1 is three times larger than what
is normal in the industry now the reason
the regular x86 amd and intel chips
don't have larger instruction buffers is
because they only have up to four
decoders so they won't even be able to
fill up a larger buffer anyway compared
to the m1s8 decoders that actually can
fill up a three times larger buffer and
the biggest issue for regular x86 chips
is that they can't add more decoders
than four because the chip has to
analyze each instruction in order to see
how long it is before using a decoder to
chop it up into micro ops because x86
instructions can be anywhere from 1 to
15 bytes long and adding more encoders
makes the whole process much more
complicated so amd themselves said that
four decoders is an absolute limit for
them but for the m1 chip each arm
instruction is always four bytes long no
matter what so it doesn't get as
complicated so apple can basically add
as many decoders as the chip can handle
which basically means that they can
theoretically add even more in the
future while x86 chips are basically
stuck with only four and this is what
allows apple's m1 cores to essentially
process twice as many instructions as
amd and intel cpus while at the same
clock speed now it doesn't stop there
because there are even more huge
advantages with the m1 chip which brings
us to an article from andre at anantak
the m1 chip actually uses eight memory
channels which is super impressive
because the 10 gen intel chip and the
high-end 1800 macbook pro only supports
up to two channels and even the newer
11th gen intel i7 chip still only
supports two channels so having eight
channels gives the m1 chip a super
impressive 68.25
gigabytes per second peak memory
bandwidth but making it even better a
single m1 high performance core achieves
memory copies of 60 to 62 gigabytes per
second almost fully saturating the
memory controllers thanks to the eight
memory channels which is apparently
something that andre has never seen in a
chip design before all of this basically
helped the m1 achieve the highest single
core performance seen in any chip higher
than the flagship 5950x
from amd and the high memory bandwidth
and unified memory architecture also
helped the m1's eight core gpu be the
fastest integrated gpu ever made and
here's another fun fact from david smith
retaining and releasing an ns object
takes around 30 nanoseconds on a current
gen intel chip and only around 6.5
nanoseconds on the m1 chip or 14
using rosetta 2 to emulate x86 intel
code and if you have no idea what this
means glitch parrot explained that
creating and destroying objects in
memory which is done all the time in
modern programming is much faster on m1
than it was on intel and this is
basically why our 900 m1 mac mini with
only 16 gigs of ram was able to
outperform our 15 000 mac pro with
192 gigs of ram in terms of xcode
programming with our max tech xcode
benchmark so yeah the m1 chip is
incredibly impressive so impressive that
it's actually getting windows focused
youtubers to recommend the new m1 max in
short this is the best computer i've
ever owned shocking news i know
considering how many notebooks have gone
through my hands how many pcs i've built
myself
but welcome to my long term review of
the macbook air m1 base model and why i
think you should get one it's weird
right as a reviewer it's becoming harder
and harder to recommend windows devices
over
what m1 macbooks offer and this is only
for this type of like an ultrabook right
stuff for work or school or just like
productivity-based stuff i guess what
i'm saying is even if you were to go out
of your way to point out the flaws it's
hard not to recommend either of the m1
macbooks they really are just that good
and now let me finally finish off with
what you should expect for the future of
course we're expecting the new
redesigned macbook pros to come most
likely in october with the new m1x chip
so let me expect what to expect from
that the m1x will most likely use the
same exact course as the m1 built on
tsmc's five nanometer process except
that it will have double the performance
cores half the efficiency cores and
either double or quadruple the number of
gpu cores basically making it the
fastest ship in any laptop now the m2
chip is basically going to be the
replacement for the m1 coming out
sometime next year using a similar chip
layout but instead using apple's newer
a15 cores built on tsmc's updated five
nanometer plus process and mark german
believes that it will remain with the
same 8 core cpu layout except that it
would add two more gpu cores to boost
graphics power a bit more and i
personally believe that the m2 will be
built on the newer arm v9 instruction
set which will come with a bunch of
improvements like sve2 to improve
performance even further and going
deeper into the future i expect there to
be m2x m3x and 4x chips and so on for
the high performance consumer max like
the high-end macbook pros as well as the
m2 m3 m4 chips and so on for the lower
end macs like the macbook air and the
smaller imac and the way i imagine apple
pulling that off is by slowly increasing
core counts of the cpu and gpu as well
as continuing to use better process
notes from tsmc like four nanometer
three nanometer two nanometer and so on
and they'll probably rotate between
using those two methods to improve
performance between chip generations so
with all of that said hopefully you
learned something new about apple's m1
chip and how it works in this video and
if you enjoyed it go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]